the pigeonhole principle is a counting
principle that's so obvious that you may
not have noticed that you're using it in
simple form it says that if there are
more pigeons then pigeon holes then you
have to have at least two pigeons in the
same hole okay
we'll get some mileage out of that
shortly but let's remember that this is
actually just an informal way of saying
something that we formerly seen already
one of the mapping rules is that if you
have a total injection from a set a to a
set B that implies that the size of a is
less than or equal to the size of B and
taking the contrapositive of that it
means that if the size of a is greater
than the size of B then no total
injection from A to B as possible no
total injection means that there's no
relation that has an arrow out of
everything in a and at most one arrow in
to be if everything out of a has an
arrow out of it there have to be at
least two arrows two pigeons coming to
the same pigeon hole in B so we know
this rule already and the only thing
that's surprising about it is how you
make use of it we're not gonna make
elaborate uses of it in this little
video you can read in the text about
some amusing applications about proving
that there have to be three people in
the Boston area with more than 10,000
hairs in their heads but the exact same
number or that there have to be two
different subsets of of ninety numbers
of twenty-five digits that have the same
sum but we will take a much more modest
application of the pigeon holing
principle namely
if I have a set of five cards then I
have to have at least two cards with the
same suit why well there are four suits
spades hearts diamonds clubs indicated
here and if you have five cards there's
more pigeons cards than suits holes so
if you're going to assign a pigeon to a
hole again the pigeons are gonna have to
crowd up they're gonna have to be at
least two pigeons in the same
all at least two cards of the same suit
maybe more okay
it's like generalization suppose I have
ten cards how many cards must I have of
the same suit what number of cards at
the same surah my guaranteed to have no
matter what the ten cards are well now
if I have the four slots that I'm trying
to distribute ten cards is it possible
that I had less than three cards in
every hole no because if I have only two
cards in every hole then I have at most
eight elements and I got ten to
distribute in the four slots I have to
bunch them up and pen have at least
three cards of the same suit you can
check that I needn't have any more of
course so the reasoning here is that the
number of cards with the same suit is
gonna be what you get by dividing up the
ten cards that you have by the four
slots and argue that at least one of the
slots has to have an average number of
cards namely ten over four they can't
all be below average and of course since
there are an integer number of cards you
can round up this remember these corner
braces mean round up to the nearest
integer so 10 divided by four rounded up
is three and that's a lower bound on the
number of cards that you have to bunch
up in one slot well generally if I have
n pigeons and I'm gonna be assigning
pigeons to unique holes and if I have H
holes then some hole has to have n
divided by H rounded up again and
divided by H can be understood as the
average number of pigeons per hole and
it's the pigeonhole principle can be
formulated as saying at least one hole
has to have greater than or equal to the
average number and that is the
generalized pigeonhole principle